she's violent so stealthy skill  sometimes oh hi this isn't what you  think it is a little awkward you can see  more to violet and Disney Pixar's  Incredibles 2 in theaters June 15th is  Jack Jack super power super playful I  can't keep giving him cookies super  hungry you can see more of Jack Jack and  Disney Pixar's Incredibles 2 in theaters  June 15 these - totally fast totally  cool totally in trouble you can see more  of - in Disney Pixar's Incredibles 2 in  theaters June 15 honey things haven't  spiraled up control the moment I left  everything's great parenting is rolling  looks normal to me is freaky  [Music]  I'll watch the kids no problem  not the way you're supposed to do why  did they change matter he's in excellent  health  [Music]  is freaky Disney Pixar's Incredibles to  see the full trailer online now  [Music]  is that a new job doing hero work I  couldn't have done this if you hadn't  taken over so well Pixar see Incredibles  2 in theaters June 15 this